perfecto ya casi acabamos y estamos en
el problema número 19 el problema número
19 que dice si a b c y f
si a bs.f dejamos apuntarnos aquí a b c
y f son números distintos de 0 es decir
ninguno de estos es 0 todas las
siguientes proporciones son equivalentes
excepto y no tengo idea de por qué
pusieron efe y no pusieron de yo
esperamos nada de pero bueno
veamos dice el inciso a el inciso dice
/ efe es igual a b / c
ok a ver vamos a ver el inciso b el
inciso b dice
efe / c es igual a b entre a y sabes que
no espera
déjame mejor escribirlos de la siguiente
manera voy a pasar a estos elementos
cruzados voy a pasar la f multiplicando
la b
la seo multiplicando la creo que va a
ser mucho más fácil visualizarla así o
dicho de otra manera como f y c son
elementos distintos de 0 voy a
multiplicar todo por c por efe y me va a
quedar que a porsche porsche estoy
cruzando estos dos es exactamente lo
mismo que b por efe ok esto en el inciso
a en el inciso b me queda este por este
y este por éste y me va a quedar que a
por efe es igual hace por b en esto del
inciso b
estos dos no se parecen pero veamos que
nos dice el inciso c en el inciso se me
dice se entrega es igual a efe entre b
pues lo mismo vamos a cruzar estos dos y
desde aquí me va a quedar que se por de
o benz porsche es lo mismo es igual a
por efe ok
este y éste son iguales me parece
interesante vamos a ver qué me dice el
inciso d el inciso de me dice a en 13 a
en 13 es igual a d
/ efe ab / efe de ti obtengo que a / efe
este por éste es igual a esto por éste
que es
y que cree eso esto es igual a este que
es igual a este que es igual a este y
aquí en general lo que estamos buscando
es el negrito del arroz es decir estoy
buscando cuál de estos es distinto y
pues parece es el que es el inciso a de
hecho bueno la respuesta es el inciso a
se nota ya claramente pero para que no
nos quedemos con la duda vamos a ver qué
me dice el inciso en el inciso e me dice
a efe / se ve esto igual a 1 y de aquí
voy a obtener se multiplicó todo x se ve
que a efe es igual a se ve que es lo
mismo que éste que es lo mismo que éste
que es lo mismo que éste que es lo mismo
que éste y aquí está ya más claro no se
puede el inciso am es mi respuesta
correcta porque es el único que es
distinto a todos los demás y es lo que
me preguntaban todas las siguientes
proporciones son equivalentes excepto el
inciso a y ya está mi respuesta es el
inciso am y esto estaba muy fácil si
nosotros pasamos cruzando esto este pase
para que multiplicando y bueno vamos a
ver qué me dice el problema número
20 el problema número 20 que me va a
decir y cambiemos de color para hacerlo
un poco más colorido a mí me gusta
utilizar este color dice si te fin a la
operación cuadrado de la siguiente
manera x cuadrado y esto es igual a x 10
- james entonces a sean a b entre los
positivos esto es muy importante sea a y
b enteros enteros y además positivos
positivos ok entonces a no puede ser 0 b
no puede ser 0 nissan ser enteros y
positivos nos preguntan si a iverson
entre los positivos cuál de las
siguientes afirmaciones puede ser igual
a 0
y bueno me dan las siguientes
afirmaciones la primera me dice a
cuadrado b a cuadrado b esto de pura
casualidad puede ser igual a cero pues
vamos a ver si la operación cuadrado
está definida de esta forma entonces
esto me quedaría como a por ven a por b
- b y que es necesario para que esto
fuera igual a cero esto sería igual a
cero 10 más se puede actualizar una vez
esto es lo mismo que ve que multiplica a
a menos 1 b no puede ser 0 de eso si
estamos completamente seguros porque b
tiene que ser un entero positivo pero
qué pasa si a vale 1 cuando a vale 1 es
un entero positivo y en este caso sí a
vale uno me quedaría b - b y b menos b
es lo mismo que 0 por lo tanto esta
expresión si puede ser cero si vale 1 en
el caso que valga 1 entonces esta
expresión se puede hacer 0 por lo tanto
la afirmación número
no es posible muy bien y qué pasa con la
número dos vamos a ver la número dos
dice a más b cuadrado b
además ve esto cuadrado b
cuadrado b bueno pues recordemos cómo
está definida la operación cuadrado la
operación cuadrado es x por james es
decir al primer va a quedar a más ve que
multiplica a b x por james x por jr
menos bien dice que está después del
cuadrado menos b ok a irak y por
factorizar también una vez me quedaría
que esto es lo mismo que ve que
multiplica aa + b primero multiplica
este y después multiplica a uno menos
uno y que es necesario para que esta
expresión sea igual a cero bueno ven no
puede ser igual a cero porque ya sabemos
que debe de ser un entero positivo y
esto de aquí abajo
si esto de acá abajo fuera cero vamos a
suponer que cero
entonces me quedaría que más ve menos
uno fuera cero si esto fuera cero ojo
fuera cero entonces se tendría que
cumplir que a más b tendría que ser
igual a uno es decir que éste lo estoy
pasando de este lado sumando ya más b no
puede ser igual a uno porque hay un
entero positivo y p también es un entero
positivo y si sumamos dos entre los
positivos los que tú quieras nunca me
van a sumar uno imagínate que valga 1
que es lo menor que podría valer el
menor entró positivo es 1 b vale 1 que
es el menor entero positivo que se puede
tomar y a más b es decir 1 más 1 no me
daría 1 por lo tanto no hay forma de que
a más b sea igual a 1 déjenme tachar lo
está el inciso 2 no puede ser cierto
porque ambas veces no puede ser 1 y por
lo tanto éste no puede ser uno por lo
tanto esta expresión oeste de aquí no
puede ser igual
entonces el número 2 no puede ser cero y
vamos a ver qué me dice el número tres
el número tres ok me dice qué va a pasar
si yo me tomo am cuadrado además ve a
cuadrado a más b bueno pues apliquemos
otra vez la definición y la definición
me dice que esto es lo mismo por cierto
estás en paréntesis esto es lo mismo que
que x por james es decir la
multiplicación de estos dos a que
multiplica a más b ya esto le tengo que
quitar el que está después del cuadrado
que es a más be ok y de aquí puedo
factorizar a puedo actualizar una más
bien esto es lo mismo de tipo decir que
esto es lo mismo que a más b que
multiplica a su vez primero multiplicar
primero multiplicar y por otra parte
multiplica a menos 1 es decir a este
número que está aquí al lado a menos uno
estoy haciendo una factorización por
agrupación y qué creés a más b no puede
ser cero
si yo sumo dos entre los positivos estos
no me pueden dar cero
a menos uno a menos uno se puede ser
cero si vale uno
entonces me quedaría uno menos uno lo
cual es cero y cero por lo que sea cero
fíjate bien si a vale uno me quedaría a
más de menos a más b lo cual es cero por
lo tanto éste también es posible se hace
cero si es igual a uno si es igual a 1
esta expresión de aquí se hace cero esto
sería igual a cero ok por lo tanto el
número 3 también se pueden y me inciso
que me dice que el 1 y el 3 se puede es
el inciso y el inciso en me dice que 1 y
3 se pueden 1 y 3 se pueden hacer 0 que
es justo lo que concluí de este
ejercicio muy bien y acabe con este la
sección número 2 del examen número 4
perfecto así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo